et pour parler de cet aspect économique
nous sommes avec olivier delamarche
économise bonsoir olivier delamarche
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france les bourses 1 qui ont une
fois de plus plongé aujourd'hui est ce
que l'économiste que vous êtes est
inquiet bah oui je suis inquiet parce
que sinon je serais je serai
complètement fou s'il l'était pas on est
dans une situation qu'on n'a jamais
connu avec des pays qui sont à l'arrêt
totalement
même en temps de guerre c'est où on est
pas on n'est pas à ce point là donc oui
il ya de quoi être inquiet et quand je
vois quelqu'un qui nous dit on n'a pas
encore bien abaisser nos prévisions et
on sait pas encore très bien si on va
être en récession en 2020 je peux lui
annoncé on sera en récession en 2020
donc et une récession à une récession
normale ça vaut 30 40 % sur un marché
financier sur un sur un indice actions
et là comme c'est une récession
extraordinaire qu'on va avoir une
accession mondiale tous les pays vont
l'être en même temps vous pouvez tabler
sur quelque chose qui sera plutôt
compris autour de 60%
voilà donc que le chemin est en partie
fait mais n'est pas fini et puis on a vu
ce qu'on attendait 1 1 dans des
émissions précédentes
je vous l'avais dit on a les banques
centrales qui utilisent le seul moyen
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
qui est le quantitative easing donc
elles vont déverser des centaines de
milliards sur nos têtes et exactement
comme en 2008-2009 et bien qu'est ce qui
s'est passé vous avez gonfler la bulle
sur les actions et sur les actifs
financiers risée et vous n'avez
absolument pas relancer les économies
réelles
donc on le sait on sait que ça n'a aucun
impact sur l'économie réelle
on sait que ça a un impact sur les
bourses c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il veut
le faire ils veulent retenir
le les marchés pour l'instant on peut
pas dire que ça a été très efficace
parce que je pense que le marché on veut
encore plus il s'est pas satisfait des
800 milliards qu'a annoncé la fed
donc il est en train de baisser là on
est plutôt à 13 % de baisse
il est en train de baisser pourquoi pas
parce qu'il réclame plus d'argent
une vraie marge de manoeuvre selon vous
ils ont pas de marge de manoeuvre
puisque les taux d'intérêt sont déjà à
zéro
donc ça c'était un levier qu'ils avaient
avant et qu'ils n'ont plus aujourd'hui
est le seul la seule marge de manoeuvre
qu'ils essaient de ces l'impression
monétaire sans limite
donc ils vont l'utiliser on l'a vu ils
ont commencé il ya eu des annonces
et puis mes mais c'est juste une
histoire de quantité et maintenant
qu'est ce qui va se passer
ils ne peuvent plus reculer c'est à dire
que s'il a fait si la fed si la bce
si la bo j arrête de deux de leurs
achats sur les marchés
eh bien les marchés continueront à se
casser la figure
mais je vous dis on est encore on est
encore quelques 20 points à 20% de trous
sur les sur les marchés le le japon n'a
rien à faire sur sur les niveaux actuels
le japon il doit être autour de de dix
mille onze mille sur sur le nikkei
pourquoi parce qu'ils vont avoir une
récession monstrueuse je vous rappelle
que le dernier trimestre japonais était
à -6 3% en annualisé alors que
le le quoran au virus n'était pas là au
dernier trimestre times n'est venu que
en 2020 donc il faut pas s'imaginer qui
aura pas de récession au japon
celle que la france a mis 12 ans je
parle sur votre contrôle pour se
remettre de la dernière récession
quels sont vos pronostics pour celle ci
qui semble peut-être encore plus
importante
elle est beaucoup plus importante et
puis c'est surtout qu'on ne s'en est pas
remis delà de la récession c'est à dire
que c'est bien là le problème c'est que
normalement dans un cycle normal vous
refaites du gras vous avez des
rémunérations qui qu'il augmente vous
avez un chômage qui diminue franchement
on est on est au plein emploi dans les
anciens cycle c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et donc vous partiez finalement de
très haut avec des croissances fortes
etc
et puis vous aviez une récession mais là
vous n'avez pas fait de gras les gens
n'ont pas fait grâce bien pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il ya des gilet jaune dans
la rue depuis un an et demi donc il n'ya
pas de gras on n'a pas fait baisser le
chômage
donc on va partir de déjà d'un état qui
est très mauvais donc il faudra pas se
penser que vous allez comme j'entends
certains dire que vous allez avoir une
reprise en v c'est à dire une reprise
avec une pente ascendante quasi aussi
forte que la pente descendante pour
aller en session c'est idiot parce que
ça va faire des dégâts qui seront des
dégâts irréparables alors vous n'êtes
pas là vous coupez quelles vont être les
conséquences sur les citoyens français
tout simplement les économies
en dans les banques ni mobilier et chose
qui intéresse un petit peu tout le monde
finalement les banques vous avez vu qu
en bourse elles sont au plus mal et
quand les banques sont au plus mal en
bourse c'est qu'a priori il se passe
quelque chose de pas très sympa dans
l'eure dans leur bilan donc oui on est
en risque majeur sur sur les banques
même si la banque centrale imprimera
tout ce qu'il faut pour essayer de les
tenir à bout de bras mais mais en étant
risques majeurs vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui sortent leur argent des banques
fin et on on sait que ça va pas ça il
faut pas se font arrêter de se faire des
illusions en permanence on n'a jamais
réglé le problème qui a eu en 2008 on a
mis la poussière sous le tapis la
poussière est en train de ressortir et
et ça va être ça va être affreux et b
aujourd'hui on a des banques centrales
qui sont on va dire mono'i des mots nos
mots nos actions qui ne savent qu'une
seule chose qu'ils ne savent faire
qu'une seule chose c'est imprimé
descendre à la cave et imprimés mais
descendre à la cave est imprimé ça n'a
jamais réglé aucun problème
faire de la dette pour régler un
problème de dette c'est idiot je pense
que tout le monde peut comprendre que
quand yagg
il ya il ya un acteur qui est surendetté
le pour le sortir de là vous n'allez pas
lui remettre de la dette c'est pas c'est
complètement où on nous voit par exemple
le lay le cas de la grèce
en grèce c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est à
dire qu'on a continué joyeusement les
endettés et la grèce ne peut pas s'en
sortir maintenant la grèce elle est sous
perfusion en permanence et elle ne
pourra pas s'en sortir
et bien quand vous avez donc une
situation qui est déjà très dégradées
qui n'a pas été réglé
eh bien vous rajouter là-dessus un
événement comme le corps n'a vu virus
qui arrivent là dessus qui d'abord
déclenché les choses et ensuite les
aggrave et mais des pays à l'arrêt
l'italie est à l'arrêt depuis plus d'un
mois nous on va être à l'arrêt à partir
de maintenant les tous les autres pays
européens c'est la même chose on est à
l'arrêt sais pas si vous rendez compte y
a plus rien qui sort des chaînes de
production
donc il faut pas s'imaginer que ça va
bien se passer que que monsieur macron
va compenser exactement toutes les
pertes de toutes les entreprises de tous
les de tous les acteurs économiques face
est ridicule on sait bien qui pourra pas
donc à arrêtons de rêver enfin il nous
enfume comme à chaque fois on a
l'impression de quelqu'un qui sait
absolument pas où il va qui gère au jour
le jour les choses qui demandent à des
experts qui en sont pas qu'ils changent
d'avis comme de chemise
enfin on n'est pas dirigée n'y a pas de
pilote dans l'avion et et tout le monde
continue à chanter à boire du champagne
en se disant ça va bien se passer non ça
va pas bien se passer si personne ne
sait piloter on va se crasher
merci olivier daunais rare je sais pas
si je dois vous remercier pour toutes
ces mauvaises nouvelles mais je vous
remercie
quand même en tout cas pour votre
analyse en direct sur rt français